[Music]
in online dating news submitted by left
tomato Matt shares plummet after
Facebook reveals dating feature trust
face blow need that Mark Zuckerberg
is getting a bit trouble for selling off
was the selling our information I don't
even know why no it's the Cambridge
analytical think I'm an average ass
person that just sees people that are
going on news and I'm like you're bad
now anytime anytime anything watch them
using mute but anytime anything's free
of course or Sonya you are you are the
product mmm I know they make their money
yeah but we love it we don't publish
soul truth we don't want to hear the
truth we love to sell our info that why
if I'm looking at hotel rooms on a
website then all of a sudden on
Instagram the same hotel I was looking
to know you know mode or the new [ __ ]
connect to my found me the new [ __ ]
which is like me and Nikki like being
like hey we should take a trip to France
in our have had that and then [ __ ] we
get advertisement I've had that because
of Alexa oh there we go no and because
of our phones yeah come on dude yeah you
guys just gotta say the right worry I
wish I had a million dollars and then
Alexa your bank accounts like a minute
oh wow that's a good loophole for the
wrong few million dollars I didn't even
set up Siri because that [ __ ] listening
no no yes
I'll get like funky exactly I'll get
like Balinese - oh yeah 10 million euros
yeah
hip pain yer [ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah I'll
get some Bob way dollar
what is not like a trillion dollars like
two sensors I think it's something like
that yeah there's literally like a ten
trillion dollar bill yeah so the shares
of a match group which owns tinder and
OkCupid plunged 22% after Facebook
unveiled this new dating feature oh [ __ ]
that's amazing
the other two companies were publicly
traded a match group which other
companies yeah I don't know okay Cubism
Wow yeah that's like snapchat dawg yeah
one out more now for snapchat yeah point
out for the homies yeah
that means they passed away pour out a
little water lady I can't believe you're
disgracing our office like that it's
beautiful that actually probably cleaned
up that floor my foot gets dirtier here
than it is outdoors poor snapchat man
those guys had the opportunity to sell
for like what was it three builders they
never sold it three billion one of the
guys cashed out recently didn't he did
he I think he did I think not for that
much though there's a stupid amount of
money though there's still a lot of
[ __ ] no bill though it's like once
you get offered three billion and then
you cash off for a hundred million you
still feel like you lost ya know when
you we need three billion your I don't
know if it's a hundred million but I'm
just relative to eat my [ __ ] [ __ ]
instead and then six months later like
you guys are getting rekt in the stock
market and [ __ ] you look like an [ __ ]
I mean think about it like my and open
as my space Tom still sold my space for
like several million but he's still
living good yeah you know like how much
money he could've let me better he could
have lived better yeah we like better
though you can always look better hey
you know I can't say it sunny optimism
okay Ryan cut it out no we're trying to
[ __ ] on these millionaires we're trying
to tell they could have had way more
fight [ __ ] those guys Bucky's snapchat
[ __ ] all these wall to far too far see
these guys lately I can't win these guys
get a couple mil sure they move to
Thailand so you can live richer but what
if they could have lived here San Fran
you know I'm saying true like as a as a
normal person again say no
as a sultan so be the sultan of San Fran
there's a sultan of san fran well third
would there could be recorded one I
don't know I think from a hundred mil to
a billion unless you're trying to do
more like [ __ ] if you're just living
that's I don't know I don't eat it what
if you want to like two Jet's that's
what we can like if you're trying to do
more if you yeah that's just if you want
to be with you yeah extra you try to be
dan Bilzerian extra then 100 mils has
Dan Bilzerian been to space yet no
because when you go to space I think
Richard Branson beverage has he been to
space ah maybe he hasn't been to space
yet so zero-g first thing does that
count
oh gee I don't leave that space I think
that's just how they fly if the outer
room
it only counts when you like you you
build your own spaceship and girls oh hi
Betty's working like Eva I must so
that's super extra yeah that's very
extra but because you're not even
visiting anybody that's true you just
I'm going to this random distance but
how cool is that you learn can you say
that that's true I've been to a place
that no one has no one else is there
God what's the story about again this is
about Facebook dating yeah how do we get
there well here's my question I thought
people been dating on Facebook without
even needing to date on the Facebook app
yeah but now there's an actual dating
feature like a function that you can
create a profile that's similar to
tinder and Bumble and that's pretty cool
I think this is genius actually I know
cuz Zuckerberg was saying that 200
million people on Facebook lists
themselves at single so there's clearly
something in there and you don't have to
battle the stigma oh you date online you
know because there's still some people
that are like hesitant there's still
fast I think so it's point people that
are like still hesitant let's say
someone recently divorced 4045 whatever
they might don't know what they might
they might think like online dating is
weird but then they're like what Marty
on Facebook and there's extra feature
just click on it or whatever yeah and so
they're saying that especially after
this whole Cambridge analytical thing
they're just stressing that you know
your privacy and
Safety's the dirty bill sucks videos
we'll be safety
I find this funny because wasn't like
Zuckerberg the ones like yeah you know
what we think that people should spend
less time on Facebook like there is that
whole like press release it's like we
think people should spend less now he's
creating this look at this new feature
where you could spend even more time on
Facebook you know it's funny though like
when people do get into a relationship
they get off Facebook so that's actually
worse for them they don't want people
that are together they want them single
not really cuz then once people get
there also those couples that once they
get together then they're just
constantly posting about their
relationships or if you're like like
older couples like that's been together
for like twenty thirty years then they
start going back on Facebook again I saw
a study that was like if the the more
frequently that your post on Facebook
the more likely it is that your
relationship is is going down you need
to validate that yeah yeah I'm not
interesting what does that say if I
don't even remember my facebook password
then you have a really successful
marriage I have three Facebook's and I
don't know what the passwords to any of
them see I don't remember the last time
I logged into Facebook that's how much I
hate Facebook then one of the profile
photos is me in a skit with the afro
from like 2007 there you go it was
someone else's video quite that was a
funny picture and I thought oh that's
photo online I just use it for articles
I use my fam page a lot mmm not a lot a
lot it would probably be like once every
two weeks yep I do laughs remember when
they made you you have to pay to reach
your own fans I was like [ __ ] Facebook
forever yes so it's like it's like if
you poke this happened to me I remember
a couple years ago it was like if you
want to post and have your post reach
all these people that you got to like
your page you have to pay this amount of
money that's stupid yeah well that's
because they're having a [ __ ] of a time
monetizing Facebook that's the kind of
[ __ ] they started doing so I don't like
Facebook one I don't like it either
because I have way more fun on YouTube
Twitter and Instagram I really like
Twitter right now I think I'm more of a
Twitter person I like your tweets thank
you very much I know you've been
tweeting a lot more often to me to
winter doesn't even exist anymore I just
think it's like an old person's media
enough like Twitter Facebook are both
like all old people stuff
now and I think that all the new the new
cool [ __ ] is Instagram I don't even know
my password to Twitter either yeah I
feel like Twitter came back cuz it did
kind of die for a while but then now a
lot of people are active on it again
it's active because of all the political
stuff is going on right but it's it's
funnier like I find more comedy on
Twitter than I do on Instagram I mean
Instagram has its memes and it's videos
and [ __ ] like that but the type of
comedy that I do like the clever [ __ ] is
on Twitter a lot I like the breaking
news [ __ ] yeah it's always on to it yeah
your words I'm owning my words because I
still don't like it I don't go on
Twitter ever then that's the truth I
just find it very boring but but
instagrams what's up I enjoy it and I
enjoy your pictures well thank you very
much I enjoy I enjoy watching people's
Instagram stories and I enjoy listening
to Nicki watch Instagram stores for a
ridiculous amount of time well I know
before she says how busy she is sure and
like how she gets upset about how busy
she is she will watch Instagram stories
for like 47 minutes and then she'll be
like I'm so busy today like I can't do
anything I can't even talk to you right
now and I'm like X Y Z's life right now
it's a lot have you ever noticed that
you do that though cuz I do this too
where it's like it's like you just you
just sort of are on your phone for a
while right and then you kind of snap
out of it yeah and you're like where the
hell did I go this guy all the time you
ever do that when you're like oh shoot I
got to respond to that text and then you
open up Instagram instead and then
you're stuck and then you pose your
phone you go oh yeah supposed to respond
to that text and then you open up
Twitter I don't know and then you close
it and you go oh yeah remember once you
put your phone down I'll forget I'll
like walk away though text me later is
like so like what's the password to get
it good oh [ __ ] that's why I do the red
on purpose like you know how iPhones
have that option like then repeat
someone's yeah text it'll save red so
that keeps me accountable but because
that should happens and I'm like
off-book I don't want to think I read it
when I didn't read it I might've
responded and so they know I'm ignoring
them I just have the blue bubble but you
don't you forget to respond no no if I'm
having a conversation
with you yeah like let's say I know that
there's something I asked you or there's
something I know that we're in the
middle of it and we didn't end it with a
buyer or whatever then I'm expecting a
text that I have to respond to or
something oh don't forget no cuz I know
that we're in the middle of something so
then I'm like oh yeah I gotta respond to
that I gotta open up that I gotta open
that up
I forget multiple conversations going on
my oh [ __ ]
I do it all in one go so I I respond all
the all the bubble and I said don't talk
to me anymore my problem is my family
texts like we they have a big family
text chain and just my phone's gone Bing
Bing Bing Bing all day and so sometimes
I'll get important [ __ ] like Nick he's
like hey I'm like my keys are stuck in
my car I can't [ __ ] go anywhere and
I'm and I won't know because my family
group text is like ding ding ding in my
phone oh all the way down yeah I know I
just figured this out I finally figured
this out like six days ago I do that
with Michael cuz he texted so much I put
his ass on mute and then I'll check it
out then and he already resolved it on
his own yeah yeah you watch the full
circle I haven't look in it in the same
like texture do you guys think you get
to this watch can I figured out well do
you know what about this wall I don't
know I just saw this you know about this
yeah actually I just got it yeah our
text to think out loud yeah I hate it I
[ __ ] hate it it's a coping mechanism
yeah I just let him I let him get it all
out I like it it's entertaining for me
you're making fun of Michael poor
Michael is watching this right now yeah
well no you watch these videos anymore
[Music]